hi everyone its Charlie this is going to be
my Game of Thrones Season 8 episode
by video so here we go
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Game of
Thrones videos we have a whole bunch of
stuff coming up with the finale and then
all the spin-off and Game of Thrones
prequel stuff that's going to be coming
this summer there's a new round of the
HBO now giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so smoke if you got
them and obviously careful for spoilers
from episode 5
but let's burn them all top 15 and
Easter eggs so many callbacks to
previous seasons particularly season 1
and obviously during Robert's rebellion
there bunch of Easter eggs for Jaime
Lannister Kingslayer Mad King wildfire
everything going back to the beginning
as you would expect starting with number
15 the new intro if you noticed they did
something different with the recap they
transposed a whole bunch of different
voice over dialogue scenes of people
talking to Daenerys throughout each of
the seasons the Queen of thorns telling
her to be a dragon
they ended on a very particular one to
where it was Viserys from back in season
1 when he said you don't want to wake
the dragon do you so you can kind of see
where they're trying to say Daenerys is
mine state is at the beginning of the
episode the dragon has been woken and
she's on the precipice of going crazy on
everyone obviously that did then play
out through the episode but there's
still a couple moments early in the
episode when you're wondering whether or
not she's going to go one way or the other
like Varys is saying about people
flipping coins when Targaryens are born
and the realm holds its breath to see
which side lands up and he knows who Jon
Snow is I know you're going to be a good
leader but his clearly convinces
Daenerys is going to be just as bad as the
Mad King was so I think a lot of the
people talking about the episode tonight
will be focusing on what Daenerys was
doing during the episode why she reacted
certain ways it how quickly it seems
like the episodes took her in that
direction whereas normally you'd feel
like it would take her a couple seasons
to descend to this point where as we
really just taken everything away from
her the last couple of episodes but Jon
Snow shows up even though it doesn't do
any good and number 14
Daenerys executes Faris I did love the
moment that he had with Tyrion the
moment he had with his little bird -
apparently he still has little birds
even though technically he doesn't have
the little birds anymore the little
birds that he used to use in King's
Landing now serve Qyburn although not
any
or as at the end of the episode may he
rest in peace Qyburn was a great hand of
the queen while he lasted I think when
you're hearing Daenerys give Varys his
death sentence and she's so calm she
gives the calmest drew chorus that I've
ever heard come out of her mouth you
know exactly where she is basically in
the mindset of Cersei when she said I
choose violence way back I think it was
during season five when the faith came
for her normally you would expect them
to Mir Daenerys his story with Cersei
like they would be doing similar things
and their characters will be coming from
similar places and similar mindsets but
really it was a very one-sided episode
it was more like a slaughter of King's
Landing
the thing about Jon Snow when he was
talking to Varys that you should
remember too is that he makes a very
critical Ned Stark level mistake by
being so strict about his honor I serve
my queen
Daenerys is my queen even though he
can't bring himself to love her
physically the way that Daenerys wants
so number 13 Jon Snow rejects a
relationship with Daenerys this seems
like it's pretty final like I will
always serve you but I won't be with you
the way that you want so the way the
producers talked about this in the notes
after the episode is that in this moment
here Daenerys feels like she's lost all
the people closest to her so she doesn't
have that level of trust in all the
other people around her primarily Jon
Snow Tyrion and Varys have all betrayed
her so she's as isolated as you could
possibly be which is starting to make
her more and more dangerous because
obviously at this point she's not going to
listen to anything that anyone else
tells her so was almost futile for
Tyrion to try and talk some sense into
her like he tries to get her to agree to
call off the attack when you hear the
bells that'll be the key that they're
going to surrender and we call off the
attack even though it seems like she
heard him and she kind of nods her head
a little bit I don't think that she's
really listening to him too much she's
just kind of waiting for him to leave
the room but on his way out of the
throne room number 12
Daenerys says that they captured Jaime
in his look of fright like he's clearly
scared of Daenerys he's scared of her
through the entire first part of the
episode that look of terror on his face
shifts to one of horror oh my god what
are they going to do to Jaime I have to go
save him now I think they were pretty
clear with a lot of the characters final
moments together that they would be
final moments so of course 11 Tyrion
helps Jaime escape and is a very cool
twist on earlier scenes from the show so
you go all the way back to season 2 when
Jaime had been captured by the Starks
Catelyn Stark by the grace of her heart
let him out
that he could go do something good it
also reminds you of season four when
Tyrion was on trial and stuck in prison
all season long and Jaime would come sit
with him in his prison cell and they
would talk to each other about their
childhood but probably one of the best
things that they talked about is when
they talked about their childhood in
this moment here in Tyrion thanks him
for being there when they were growing
up you're the only reason I survived
everyone hated me and wanted me dead
I would not have lived to adulthood if
not for you for all the faults the show
has I feel like any time they have
Tyrion and Jaime together in a scene it
always winds up being a really good
scene they just have really great
chemistry together as actors plus even
though the writing might not be quite as
good as it was in earlier seasons the
actors have been with each other in
these scenes for so long but they've
become like brothers too
so yeah both Nikolaj coster-waldau in
Peter Dinklage that are fantastic actors
they can just work magic with the
scripts with whatever they're given
remember what Daenerys told Tyrion
though you fail me again and that's it
for you basically telling him that she
would execute him so I think he's signed
his death warrant the minute that he
helped Jamie escape but he was so
horrified by what Daenerys was doing
during the episode that is possible that
he also does something at the beginning
of the finale that will cause her to
want to execute him 10 was Daenerys
destroying the iron fleet she just cuts
through all their forces like butter so
the weird thing about this I know a lot
of people like wait a minute how come
they were so accurate when they
Rhaegar and now that Daenerys is coming
at them they couldn't hit water if they
fell out of a boat which a lot of them
wind up doing even though in a logic
level it totally doesn't make sense from
a narrative perspective what they're
trying to show you is is that it's
basically a bloodbath
Daenerys is just massacring everyone in
King's Landing that's why there were so
many scenes on the streets of King's
Landing with the peasants just running
around being terrified they just wanted
to show you how crazy it was people
screaming for mercy in Daenerys not
giving any of it and even earlier in the
episode when she was talking to Tyrion
she started talking about how her mercy
would be the future generations
benefiting from not being under the rule
of a tyrant basically telling Tyrion
that she had no problem with collateral
damage she had no problem cutting
through Circe's meatshield of citizens
that she was letting into the red keep
nine
Daenerys destroys the golden company
easily is almost like they never
mattered this is kind of funny in a bad
way like wait a minute what's going on
here the golden company they're so cool
nope boom she's just
at the gates of King's Landing from the
rear and even though it's a really cool
effect it's kind of disappointing that
we didn't get to see them actually fight
in battle because they really are legit
badasses when you actually do get to see
them fight but now it makes sense why
they didn't spend the extra money to
make those CG elephants or to get real
elephants to like we're just going to blow
them up in five seconds what's the point
of spending an extra half a million
dollars just to get a couple elephants
in the scene so I will understand if
you're very very upset about how quickly
that part of the battle was over but
like I said I think it's all in service
of making Daenerys seem like this all
terrible powerful force that nobody's
going to be able to stop even Jon Snow
has trouble stopping his own troops in
the streets later she also cut right
through all those scorpions along the
wall it's almost like they didn't even
matter either like the way she cuts them
down it's just hilarious how quickly she
gets through all of them aid was
Daenerys going rogue after Tyrians plan
had worked to get the Lannisters to
surrender so it gets really quiet for a
sudden and Jon Snow breathes a sigh of
relief even Tyrion seems like he's
getting ready to breathe a sigh of
relief but they do this weird 360 shop
where they go to Daenerys his
perspective and she hears all the bells
all over the city ringing in discord and
even though it seems like she's going
full Mad Queen slowly what the producer
said about this scene is that it's the
moment that Daenerys decides to make the
fight personal and she's not thinking
about the battle she's just thinking
about living in exile her whole life all
the things that drove her away from her
family's home that they built 300 years
ago and because it's within her sight
she doesn't want to wait anymore she's
like that's it it's personal I'm coming
/ Cersei so the thing about that though
is that she just starts strafing all up
and down the city she doesn't fly in a
straight line to the red cape she's
actually lighting up streets going
across King's Landing winding her way to
the red cape which seemed kind of weird
to me she was really going for those
extra points on environmental damage
just trying to blow everything she
possibly could up things get even worse
though number seven even the northern
soldiers go completely vicious in a
remind you of the riots during season
two when the mob came for Joffrey in the
Hound had to save salsa from those men
that were trying to take her so John
does the same thing but it's one of the
northern soldiers one of his own
soldiers that's trying to take one of
the women of King's Landing who he then
saves the northern soldier tries to
Jon Snow his own commander the most
special boy next to
and he tries to take him out like what
is going on in the minds of this soldier
here everything goes into this complete
frenzy but you finally get number six
Jamie versus you're on so this actually
felt kind of weird too like where did
your on come from was he just waiting
here this whole time for Jamie to walk
by this is one of the rear escape routes
that Tyrion was talking about it's not
the one that he told Jamie to take but
it's another one there are many paths in
and out of the red keep when king maegor
was having the red key built
he actually had a bunch of secret
passages built in and out in that when
the workers were done he held a feast
and gave them a version of a red wedding
so that none of them could live to tell
anyone the secrets of the red keep so
there are a lot of ways that you can
sneak in and out I was actually
surprised about how much they did not do
during this Jamie you're on fight they
really wanted it to be over quickly I
felt like they were going to reference the
baby like I put a baby in your sister
and I felt like Jamie was going to tell him
no it's my baby and that would make your
on even matter but it sounds like you're
on just wanted to him just because
for the pleasure I can't believe that
I'm the one that got to Jamie
Lannister
he dies a happy man knowing that he
would have killed Jamie Lannister
but haha surprise joke's on him Jamie
got by the roof collapsing number
five wildfire starts erupting all over
the city that wildfire is probably left
over from the mad Kings days remember
when Jamie Lannister was telling the
story to Brienne about why he became the
Kingslayer he said that the mad king who
had become paranoid slowly over many
years had been using the pyromancers to
lay traps of wildfire all over King's
Landing during the siege of King's
Landing the very end of Robert's
rebellion the Mad King finally said okay
we're going to burn them all you have that
scene that brand flashback to that we
all referenced burn them all which was
supposed to be the signal to the
pyromancers to enact his plan and blow
everything up but obviously Jamie
decided that that was completely bonkers
so he killed the Mad King thus becoming
the King Slayer saving all of King's
Landing Tyrion referenced that a little
bit when he was talking to Jamie about
escaping think of the million people in
King's Landing about saving them Jaime
claims that he doesn't care about them
in that moment but I think that that's
not true but boy Tyrion does try to sell
him on that life on the run just go to
Pentos sail away start a new life with
that new baby of yours sure I'm sure
it'll happen I'm sure you totally won't
get blown up in this Daenerys fire
speaking of goodbyes number four Arya
says her final goodbyes to the Hound you
could kind of tell that it was there
last goodbye just because the way things
were headed in the episode you come with
me you die look at me my life has been
all about revenge he doesn't mention his
brother but obviously that's what he's
been thinking about his whole life do
you want to wind up like me so she sort
of comes to her senses and realizes that
maybe that's not the end of it and then
takes off obviously this is not the end
of it though because you just see Aria
at the end of the episode you just see
her riding towards the gates of King's
Landing so I do think that she's going
to be a big part of the finale so it's
not like she's completely left the story
at this point
I'll talk about it a little more when I
post my finale trailer video but
remember how Aria showed up to King's
Landing to the Queen I think that
she still wants to the Queen at
this point just not the Queen that she's
wanted to this entire time
I think she's going to set her sights on
Daenerys but I don't think if Daenerys
does wind up being killed in the finale
I don't think that Arya would be the one
to do it
remember how Melisandre talked about
Arya closing green eyes well Emilia
Clarke also has green eyes in real life
so you can take that any way you want
but like I said if Daenerys winds up
dying in the finale I don't think that
Arya is going to be the person to do it
even if she is involved with it somehow
number three though Clegane bol get hype
the thing that we've asked for this
whole time they finally deliver on is
probably one of the biggest payoffs of
the episode I think you know of all the
things that people complain about
I feel like across the board cleganebowl
will be one of the few things the people
like in this episode it was both
hilarious and throughout the entire
fight the Hound lapping as he landed
blow after blow on the mountain not
phasing him he even gets in through the
face and it still doesn't faze him but
we finally get to see the mountain
without his helmet on and then without
his armor on for the first time since
Qyburn brought him back he looked about
the way I expected him to look it was
kind of hilarious the way he dashed
Qyburn against the wall nearby when he
commanded him to stop stay by your queen
Boop nope you're gone r.i.p Qyburn there
are a couple Easter eggs during the
fight itself - he dashed Qyburn against
the wall the way he dashed baby Aegon
Rhaegar son with Elia Martell against
the wall and he tried to take out the
mountains eyes the same way he did to
Oberyn Martell during season 4 I'm not
expecting them to show up during the
finale I think that they either died on
impact or later in the fire I think
that's the whole idea it was a fairly
satisfying poetic end for them like
their beginning was that fire when the
mountain held his face into it for
taking his toy so they die in fire at
the end together
number two was jaime and cersei 'he's
death in the collapse underneath the red
keep this is actually right underneath
the throne room 2 where Robert used to
keep all those skulls it's where the
skull of balerion the black dread was
where the prototype for the Scorpion the
Qyburn then built into the bigger ones
on the walls the whole idea was Cersei
and this is I think she sort of backed
herself into a corner and even though
she seems very sure of herself at the
beginning of the episode you can kind of
see the turn when Qyburn comes to bring
her to make ors holdfast which actually
also remind you of the Blackwater
episode that was where they were when
the battle was happening when she was
drinking all that wine giving Sansa all
those speeches just being probably the
worst queen ever telling everyone that
they were going to die or be taken by
soldiers you also remember the end of
that episode that she almost thought
that she was going to die she was ready to
take that poison with her and Tommen in
her lap the line that Jaime goes out on
nothing else matters only us I think is
either from season four after they lost
Joffrey after the purple wedding or was
after they lost Myrcella it was from
actually one of the middle seasons I
don't think it's actually a line from
season one there was a lot of season one
dialogue during the episode there was
the line from Varys when he was talking
to Jon Snow power resides where men
believe it resides when it's all said
and done yes I do think that Cersei and
Jaime were going to die but I did want to
see them get a more epic death so I was
a little disappointed with the way they
went out I was hoping for something a
little more spectacular first Cersei
just because her story has been so crazy
up to this point I thought it was weird
the way that they try to humanize her so
much and they really did want you to
sympathize with her so we'll have a lot
of conversations next we get to the
finale talking about who the real
villain of Game of Thrones winds up
being but number one Daenerys
pretty much destroys all of King's
Landing there's wildfire erupting
everywhere and big torrents of green
flame in most of the red keep but not
the throne room or the iron throne
itself we'll have to wait for that till
next week sometime but it really does
look like Daenerys has vision in the
house of the undying but now we know
because that Arya scene at the end of
the episode it's not snow on King's
Landing it's actually all the ashes from
the people you also probably noticed
they paid off a big easter egg from one
of brands visions a long time ago during
season six but he was having all those
flashbacks to the Mad King burned them
all he also had a vision of a dragon
shadow flying over King's Landing
obviously now we know that that is
drogon
because they had a very same type of
shot with Drogo
no casting over all the buildings Walden
Aires was busy striping lighting up all
that wildfire so the real question of
the day now is is whether or not you
think that Daenerys has gone full Mad
Queen in whether or not you think she's
at the point of no return will Jon Snow
or any of the others be able to talk her
back from the precipice or is it at the
point now where the citizens will never
love her like at the beginning of the
episode she kept talking to Jon Snow
everyone loves you I don't have love in
Westeros so let it be beer then so it's
almost like everyone's worst fears have
been realized so we'll talk about it
during my finale trailer video that'll
post tomorrow so leave all your
questions in the comments below and your
reactions to the episode I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that trailer
video too so click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 4 video and
click here for my episode 3 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome burn them all!